what's up everyone we are back at
blockchain for social justice we're now
say you know Scott Morris
howdy these are coming on the show man
my pleasure appreciate you having me
yeah and so you are token economist with
coin that's where I spelled qoi n yup
calm yeah check it out and so you are
building locally owned and locally run
community economies correct
okay community currencies impact tokens
participatory economies what are these
things right we just talk to Ferris a
bit yeah awareness is all we're talking
the same language so I mean really this
is about putting local communities into
the pilot seat of their own futures I
mean we're subject to so many forces in
the in this construct and the normal
financial economy that's become very
globalized for these very big entities
whether they're large international
corporations or large federal
governments for making you know kind of
sweeping decisions about things that
have impact on our lives and we have
very few avenues to effectively respond
to those things or to you know kind of
have the financing to make changes in
our communities that we know that need
to have there's just not the funding
that's available there's a whole host of
problems here but mostly what we're
recognizing is that we have really huge
huge problems like with climate change
and like all the things around
sustainable development goals some
estimates have the cost of succeeding in
that the energy thing all those goals to
be around 50 trillion dollars right and
so no entity on the planet can
accomplish those things on their own it
has to be a team effort but we have your
real pressing things we're racing a
clock here that's the primary enemy here
is time to counteract climate change
right and that's that's a big deal into
itself we've got social unrest that is
not getting better
you know people feel very isolated they
feel very desperate and because of
economic forces and great disparities in
wealth they tend to blame one another
they can be you know kind of tricked
through you know right-wing
xenophobic rhetoric for example is what
we're seeing happen here in the US you
know so you know formally middle-class
white people are suffering economically
and they want to blame somebody and
that's people who look different than
them and immigrants and that it's
actually a pattern taught history so we
don't let's unpack one of the first
things that you see and will continue
one of the first things that you pointed
out too was that kind of bringing the
the the fabric of the community back to
a point where we're engaging and
interacting with each other and we're
not dependent on a single entity whether
it be like a government that's doing
some sort of a top-down oversight or a
corporation that's the only one that's
able to provide us with the good or
service that we need yes so that seems
to be a core principle of
decentralization so tell us a bit more
about what this looks like like where's
coin being implemented today and what
does that look like for that city for
that community sure sure yeah absolutely
I mean really it's um there's there's a
couple of layers that are all kind of
working together one is around civic
engagement another is around capital
around how we are doing investing and
being doing development and then the the
lowest level I would say is current so
Civic crypto currencies is one way we've
heard this phrased these community based
currency systems there's actually
decades of history centuries millennia
depending on what you want to allow in
the conversation track records and
attempts and experimentation and run
using alternative monetary models to
generate outcomes those can be
commercially oriented they can be
socially oriented they can be
environmentally oriented but what we're
really kind of understanding is the way
that these are used to incentivize
impact and so you know the the very
radical and notion underlying all this
is that people will do the things that
they can get paid to do right and so if
you want people to do things that right
now aren't on the menu the economic
incentives aren't there for them to do
that well then create the day gets in it
like that's the thing we can do the
economy is a construct created by a lot
of human decisions and you know economic
laws such as supply and demand exist
within a construct of the money system
the money system way the money is to
design creates the very basic layer of
incentives right
for instance interest do we reward
people for hoarding right positive
interest is a reward for hoarding that's
sure right but the economy depends on
spending and circulation yeah those are
you know incentives that butt heads
right and we're actually seeing a lot of
that happening again in crypto there's
you know people are recreating mistakes
all over the place that's that's ok it
really just comes down understanding you
know kind of zen and the art of
incentive crafting right and that's what
we're we're really discussing here so in
terms of the coin model what we have is
a program called sama doon which from
Dutch translates to better together hmm
sama doon yes it's sa ma n do en Samba
tune together we're doing kind of thing
together we're doing yeah so doing
together I like to call it better
together yeah it's like you know because
there's a vote there's a qualitative
value add yeah in addition to the
quantitative results so what the coin
model represents is one of the few
fourth-generation community currencies
around the world there's there's own
videos only a couple hundred tops it's
probably still under a hundred models
that are even utilizing a number of
strategies the way that this arm what a
fourth generation applies is that it's a
hybrid model that is bringing together a
number of strategies and models and
marketplaces into one mutually
reinforcing system alright so we could
talk about the past generations but I
think it's a little off point what the
four cornerstones of that program are
rewarding people for shopping with small
businesses right small main street level
businesses rewarding people for doing
good in their communities and for
changing their behaviors and ways that
we know generate impacts and sometimes
that impact
for the bottom line of anchor
institutions there's number ways to
create multiplier effects and other you
know value ads along the value chain
here was where is this implemented oh
sorry yeah this is in the cities of
Toland and bergen op zoom and the
netherlands this is where another one's
yeah yeah exactly
interests so we're expanding and so how
does this functioning this is a this is
like a social impact token correct yeah
yeah yeah but this is not this is not
yet on chain we are we are as often this
is off chain we are moving on chain
we're doing that with some technology
partners whose token models we designed
and we're kind of green together an
alliance of technology partners that
we've worked with in one capacity or
another around place-based impact
oriented systems yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so the value of the social impact token
is determined by what when it starts so
and this is a really essential element
that is unfortunately overlooked by
community currency programs but also by
blockchain is that this if this token
exists to serve a community though the
the way that I will be serving that
community needs to come from that
community it needs to be kind of a code
development process with them there are
certain decisions that you can make in
terms of the construct you know the
nature of the offering but how its
applied needs to be code designed with
them to make sure that that is what
actually makes sense
and it's not just some notion that we
have so you bring together a
multi-stakeholder body of some sort or
another we're not picky about how its
formatted in terms of in entity or
whatever but there needs to be
engagement very early on to bring these
stakeholders together to have the
discussion and to really kind of check
assumptions
and then the values determined when I am
starting to use the social impact chart
token in my city how is the value
determined so there's different ways to
go about it where we do not design
systems that have floating prices
against other currencies we design
stable tokens that are they maintain a
price parity with the dominant currency
that exists there and there's a couple
of reasons for doing this one is just
for the simplicity so one social token
would equal a euro yes correct
that's right well or a 100th of a euro 1
euro cent Oh when your asset right so
they I mean if that point type thing
yeah so yeah that that that's important
and then the other aspect is just that
it's stable right you can provide some
baseline stability with that and then
the types of system level stability
you're able to provide with a stable
coin is different than the types of
outcomes then you'd be able to generate
with floating price and I think that
that's a debatable point people will
probably debate that but for the time
being we think that it's simpler to just
kind of stay with some sort of price
parity so what would be the difference
between me using a couple of Euro cents
versus a couple of social impact tokens
coins like what would be the difference
why would I choose to use you what's
happened right behind the C's right
that's making me go I want to use you
all the time right well I let me just
get reframe the question because I think
this is actually something that's
evident in the cryptocurrency space at
large and because we're a bunch of
techies and we think Tec is important we
forget that the vast majority of the
users that we're trying to help don't
care about tech they don't they don't
think it's interesting they don't care
what protocol your based on they don't
care you know really how the tokens
constructed the end users want what the
end users want our job is to help them
get what they want so I don't want to
convince you to use my token that's not
what I'm here to do
I'm here to create a value add to that
appeals to you might change your
behavior slightly right rather than
going and buying on Amazon you're buying
on Main Street all right now why did you
do that oh you know that when I open up
this app and I go in a shop on Main
Street I earn points and those points
the points that I'm able to earn by
shopping locally exceed the types of
points that I would earn online and then
I save up my points just like my
frequent flyer miles or my coffee card
points and then I get to redeem them I
need to go and have an enjoyable
experience on the basis of that that
generation of espresso my incentive to
use the social impact coin locally is
that I gain some sort of rewards that
are greater than the rewards that I
would gain from a conglomerate and
working with through them there's one
that's one kind of approach to it yeah
okay and then that there there seems to
be there there's still something else if
I if I do locally as well and I use
social impact coin there is there
something else like that is that the
community yeah what are these other
things as well sure so what one of the
thing is that the things that we're
opening up new ways to earn all right
one of the major problems in the the
economic system and the money system
that I don't think is really kind of
fully appreciated is that you know the
99% of the user base of that product /
service basically just doesn't have
enough access to it right vast majority
of us are pretty broke right the we know
that more and more wealth is being
concentrated up to the very very
tippity-top right is that it's like at
the end of a game of Monopoly when
player has all money everybody else is
having a totally crap time at the game
yeah but it's not over yet
right that's the general emotional
signature of our experience in the
economy right now truth and said that is
what's best what's going on so what
we're able to do is we can create new
circuits of recognition of value
creation
so there's more options in terms of
weights that I can earn purchasing power
and what we focus on doing here why it's
an impact token is that we align the
ability to earn the power to purchase
with your service to purpose right
that's the big kind of misalignment
right now is that we know that we need
to go over here to achieve the
sustainable development goals but I have
to go that way to earn money right so so
just a purpose power to purchase deadly
out of alignment so we're bringing those
back into alignment that's about it okay
yeah all right so the so the first step
of the process is to understand that
we're in a Monopoly game and that in the
Monopoly game it's now having a vast
concentration of wealth and that the
rest of us are going ok SDGs are this
way but the human race is that way right
and so money system the body system yeah
that's why it's the human race this is
like human flourishing is this way
humility doesn't always catalyze some
sort of flourishing right to maximize
human potential but let's say we do
align ourselves with this purpose that
we have of a maximizing potential human
flourishing and of of social impact with
these through these through these coins
through these impact coins so in order
to in order to get there we have to go
from relying on the centralized entities
to provides that the services it's got
to be a shift in mindset shift in
perspective to want to align ourselves
with these impact coins yeah and
basically that is as simple as you know
do you care about this goal like it
really can't be boiled down to that damn
basically just based on the values
alignment you can actually create a
monetary value flow possible will I end
up needing to pay more in the temp in
the short-term another may be dollar two
dollars on these smaller items like
toilet paper and bread and stuff like
that because it's just a little bit more
expensive to buy locally at times than
it is from a major conglomerate that can
also deliver it to me in 30 minutes
right right it's actually a very fair
question so there's a key equation that
we focus on and it is Irving Fisher's
equation of
economy and that is P of price you know
being the average price of all the goods
and services sold times t number of
transactions that is like how much value
you have in the economy so P T equals M
V the money supply times the velocity
now we cannot really have an impact on P
that's the one out of the four that we
cannot really have an effect on on the
price correct so I'm not going to be
affecting prices I'm not trying to have
an effect on price yes what we do have
an effect on is the the number of
transactions by way of increasing the
supply of money and increasing the
velocity that is those the the we've so
we focus on the right half of the
equation we can impact the number of the
the total supply of liquidity of money
in that local in that micro economy and
we that money that we introduced has a
habit of going faster circulating more
which which is a weird way to think
about it but basically has higher
performance money yeah over the same
period of time it facilitates more
economic activity so that various that's
one thing yes teaching us about how ten
million dollars stimulated with in the
local economy produces forty eight jobs
and ten million from us purchasing
through Amazon would only stimulate four
jobs so that this this idea of a of a
creating a micro economy the inside of a
city and then having the velocity of
money be just much faster going between
each other efficiencies increasing
innovation increasing quality of life
increasing community increasing that
that seems like the the route in in
rather than having the monopoly game
fall apart right and vast majority of
people just lose and there be a
speciation a socio economic status seems
like decentralization is basically
coming in right on time to save the day
if we can figure out how to proliferate
it that's right and really what it's
saying is like okay we recognize that
the game of Monopoly is in the end game
state and we can play another game even
as that continues to play out but we
start playing another game here
another game here and another game here
and another game here and that reduces
the amount of dependency and relevance
of that first game and we can start to
find these alternative channels yes
really I mean listen the economy is very
simple okay it's all about doing one
thing going from what I've got to
getting what I want right and now we've
had what we've experienced is a
bottleneck effect and the bottleneck is
how much money is available right we
have all these goods and services that
we have we have all the goods and
services that we want there's plenty of
buyers who would buy those things if
they could afford it but we all have to
go through this bottleneck of the
available money supply in order to be
able to get out to the other side what
we're doing is we're widening the
bottleneck yeah that's the that's the
effect of what we're seeing yeah okay so
what is where when when don't we will in
the u.s. be able to use coin hopefully
he I mean within the next six months to
a year so we already have the existing
technology you know or expanding in the
Netherlands good we have a really
promising situation Lisbon and Portugal
right now oh yeah
yeah and that's where like with the city
of Lisbon involves that's a really
progressive thing like you're looking at
it everything great so you know it's my
mission that's why I actually created
the sister organization with a coin
called American yeah and basically what
we're doing is taking coin global
America corn is responsible for us in
Canada and you know I am working with a
number of networks across both countries
that would use the next generation
platform that we can pull together sweet
yeah yeah yeah so I mean really as soon
as possible we're hoping that move to
tokens sales to the next year and then
is move to tokens sell within the next
year so right now the coin is not on the
chain the coins is being pushed to a
couple hundred people in these cities
well I mean a few thousand households
ousand household in those cities and
they're using the coin
they're barred they're exchanging the
coins yeah there's there's loyalty
programs or specific rewards programs
there's the sharing economy from P P
activity and automatic donations someone
will actually sell their bread for a
hundred of these yep coins yep and then
I just call them points points so 100
these points for bread and then so this
is already happening and then what about
what happens once the there is a public
sale of the coins but what what the
tokens sale will do me so our token
economy is more sophisticated than your
average token economy we are token
economist we design these things for for
as a service we are really deep into
this space so it's not like we're going
overboard here it's just a recognition
of the different layers of what we're
talking about so we have the currency
later the capital layer the civic
engagement layer and then there's a
global token that facilitates the the
the conversions between the tokens and
various local networks so that's that's
one aspect of where Bank war becomes
really useful so I think it's
appropriate to mention I'm an adviser to
the bank or foundation I have PMT but
I'm also one of the big true believers
in the Bancorp protocol the smart token
format and the value as of that brings
to token economies so we've really been
focused on how to utilize these new
tools these new classes of digital
assets to unlock new types of wealth and
to create additional system-level
benefits as a part of this architecture
and it there's a lot of a lot of
potential there yeah there's a lot more
that I need to learn to continue
unpacking this but this is interesting I
want to know what will happen once the
ico happens how they'll affect the coins
that are currently being circulated and
yeah basically my coins right very sorry
and didn't quite answer your question
there but basically these are for the
the global tokens which right now are
kind of like a license token so it's not
really about them being able to like buy
the points in a locale but there is some
connection I was going to you but
basically because it's a stable token on
the ground like kind of rows of a fixed
price it's not like them until loop to
value or anything like that it just will
open things up to each individual
location rather than just being totally
insulated it is part of a networked
whole so it allows for the
interoperability and in exchange alright
let's let's run you through a couple of
questions as we go out we're at the
social justice for blockchain event so
where does we talked a lot about how
blockchain is affecting what you're
building right now and how you're
leveraging blockchain technology to
build it it's not yet on on chain but it
will soon be on chain and they'll help
with transparency and immutability and
decentralization you're already
decentralizing quite well how about for
social justice where does this come into
play for social justice right it's an
awesome question I'm totally fitting for
the event one thing that I focus on at
least is that really what we're talking
about is you know new models of exchange
new ways of helping supply meet demand
and demand meet supply where that
happens is in a place we call a market
or a marketplace and marketplaces in
kind of an abstract away can generally
be classified into one of four
categories you know I actually met the
team that is now Bank [ __ ] before they
were Bank or when they were doing a
marketplace application they brought to
me and my capacity is the founder of the
local currency and ethica called ethic
Ashe which succeeded the local currency
they're from the 90s called the Ithaca
hours and so I started using this
marketplace app it was very
sophisticated you create
any kind of two-sided marketplace and
there you have a bunch of them and
networked them together it was awesome
but I need to figure out how to wield
that and so what I found were like okay
what are the different types of
marketplaces like what how are people
using these things and it kind of like
really took a deep dive on it and you
know things like Airbnb and uber or what
I call utility marketplaces where they
just aggregate the supply of a given
good or service to make that easier for
the demand side to find and it also
creates some price stability price
regularity there are three other classes
one is locality where we all just live
in the same place there's another that
is affinity like hey we're members of
the same group like chambers of commerce
or whatever and the Nexus of solidarity
and I think that is really where we hit
on the answer to your question here
because it's known that black Americans
are at the bottom right bottom bottom of
the economic pyramid and in fact it's
been calculated that in or the number of
years it would take for the average
black American family to build the same
level of wealth enjoyed by the average
white American family today you know I
take like 300 years at the rate that
we're going because we're actually you
know diverging you know so what we need
are these dedicated channels that are
devoted to channel and cash and capital
into these sectors that are starved how
Harvey says capital well you can have a
marketplace that is like the by black
marketplace you can have a marketplace
that's only for women-owned businesses
you have a marketplace it's only for
Native American owned businesses you
know so that's what I call the
Solidarity mark you've got it
so then solidarity marketplaces is that
I want to go and support Native American
business so I'm going to go on a site
that only has Native American businesses
and they're validated and then the same
thing for black same thing for women
same thing for whoever that's right okay
interesting so that's a way to kind of
funnel money through those communities
fast
each one of those things can have their
own token mall each one of the things
that I was only like devoted economic
circuitry of value exchange that
incentivizes that wealth to stay in that
community interesting part of that is
really important because you want to
have really valid invaluable social
justice in those areas of the world for
those people of the world but also at
the same time it seems a little bit
tribal it seems like we're continuing to
push into a tribal setting where I ain't
there there must be some sort of a way
to not be so tribal about it but be
uplifting about it relatively at the
same time yeah yeah no I agree that
there's something that's very delicate
about you know the the social dynamics
of doing these things the right way and
specifically around representation and
inclusion so that being said you know I
think that it's it's not about being
exclusive I mean because listen I mean
it's all really only a matter of time
until the white power groups do it the
same way they're like it's reverse
racism we got to have white only
marketplace like big you know I roll
okay but it's probably gonna happen okay
its blockchain is immutable
there are racists like it's just a
matter of time but you know for people
who aren't busy getting triggered by the
idea of recognizing that yes it is just
a matter of skin color melatonin levels
right whatever if we can if we can have
a positive impact by doing this great
let's do that if you don't want to buy
only Native American go for if you don't
buy only black go for it that's right oh
do you think there's a marketplace for
it that's right yeah just making the
option available and very clear but also
having an ethics and philosophy that is
also driven towards you know progressed
progression of the whole planet and have
not just your tribe
that seems to be really important moving
forward now okay let's ask you a couple
of these ending questions that we like
asking sure do you think we're alone in
the cosmos I think that it is
mathematically unlikely it's a big
cosmos out there totally and the the
physics of having a specific you know
amount of galactic dust that comes
together to form the disc that spins
together to create a star of a certain
size and to the harmonics away from that
center of gravity creating a has had
habitable thank you oh my god
habitable zone for a planet that can
happen there's a boatload of frickin
stars out there it's happened some other
place
you know whether that's now you know in
terms of the time thing like that did
that's an interesting question but I
don't think so
do you think we're in a simulation I
personally cannot prove we are not I've
hear some people experimented about that
I'll know with us it just did a bunch of
DMT or what but I cannot Steve actually
I know that I'm not living in a
simulation and then what do you think
the most beautiful thing in the world's
got people breaking free from oppressive
systems that's it
people watching people recognize and
become proficient in the language of
their own power that's the most
beautiful thing in the world mmm hell
yeah hell yeah that really resonated I
like that one great
unshackle yourself from the oppression
yeah man yeah I'm broke from the tyranny
and really be have that help with
self-actualization and collective
actualization yeah a lot it that's it
this is
been fantastic learned a lot learned a
lot and I think that there's something
about the way that we design future
communities and economies and impact
coins and I think there's something
really powerful there that you're
working on that a lot of people here
that we've talked to are talking about
so it's exciting stuff and it's a
pleasure to have learned about it from
you thanks a lot Allen thanks for coming
out with show much appreciated thanks
everyone for tuning in if you guys had a
good time
make sure comment below with your
thoughts subscribe share the content to
other people remember do not just
consume this content go create with it
make a video with it write about it tell
to people tell to people about it for
sure tell to people they'll tell to
people etc keep going and join us on
patreon you to continue sustaining this
project and continue to grow it to come
to cool places like this and continue
highlighting smart people so join us on
patreon thank you so much everyone
smart people much love peace
you